KOIVULA.
>> Butch: THERE IS NO A
DIFFERENT REASON.
ON
SETTLES IT DOWN.
SOFTLY SENDS IT DOWN THEHURRY.
ITS A FOUR MAN RUSH.
TRAUB 2-0.
12:12 NO CHANCE FOR
POINT PER GAME, BUT THE
CHEMISTRY HAS BEEN GOOD ALSO.
THLOOKING BACK AND HE SCORES!
IT'S A HAT TRICKNOBODY.
AND ANDREW COPP SAYS THA
HUGE.
SCRAMBLE IN FRONT AND THERE IT S
BROCK NELSON.
37 BOUNCE.
THERE'S THE
HE SHOOTS ONE. THE
JUST WIDE.
HE HAD A DONE IT AGAIN.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS ANGLE YOUR
STICK.
HE HITS THE T IN.
TO STROME.
ISLANDER DEFENSESE THAT.
THE ISLANDERS WITH POWER PLAY
GOALS IN THE LAST.
TWO ALSO THREE OF THERES!
SECOND OF THE NIGHT FOR BROCK
NELSON.
POWER PLAY GOAL A SLOT.
HE GOES FIVE
PANARIN.
BARZAL THE WALL.
OFF THE RIGHT-HE
CROSS-ICE AWAY.
FINES DOBSON.
BACK ACROSS.
AND THEY SCORE.
IT'S JOSH DOBSON.
WAITING.